[MUSIC PLAYING]
When you first enter the
world of automated testing,
you might be overwhelmed with
some of the terminology-- unit
tests, instrumented
tests, mocking.
It can be a little
daunting to even start
to learn about testing.
If you're watching
this video, you're
probably looking for an answer
to one simple question--
how do I start adding
tests to my app?
Don't worry, that's
what's Android
testing patterns is all about.
But please, bear with me.
Let's start with some basics.
This is the testing pyramid.
It represents the
various levels or types
of tests you can
add to your app.
Unit tests are perhaps the
most basic type of tests,
but basic is not the
same as unimportant.
In fact, they should form the
foundation of your whole test
strategy.
That's why they sit at
the bottom of the pyramid.
Unit tests verify the
correctness are the smallest
units of your code, such
as methods and classes,
in isolation from the
rest of the code base
or even the platform
they will be running on.
In fact, you can actually run
unit tests for Android apps
on your computer thanks to
support from Android Studio
and Gradle.
If it's unclear to
you why you should
test code in isolation from
Android, think of it this way--
how can you even begin
to check if your banking
app, for example, runs
on an Android device
without first making
sure that basic business
logic, such as
currency conversions
or calculating an account
balance, work correctly?
But you are writing an
Android app, after all.
So you need to be able to
test how your code behaves
on a real device or emulator.
And that's when you'd want
to use instrumentation tests.
Why do we call them
instrumentation
or instrumented tests?
Instrumentation is an
Android framework component
that provides additional
monitoring and control
over the application
Android test.
For the use of
instrumentation, we
can run tests on a
real device or emulator
alongside your app's code.
How does that work?
Well, the test
that you write will
be packaged into a
separate APK and installed
as part of the connected
Android test Gradle task
or when running tests
in Android Studio.
They will then be executed
in your app's process
by an instrumentation runner.
We provide a runner
implementation
that is compatible with JUnit4
tests as part of the Android
Testing Support
Library, or ATSL.
To use it, make sure you
have the newest version
of Android Support Repository
installed within your SDK.
The ATSL comes with a
great UI testing framework
called Espresso
that I will focus on
in the next few episodes of
Android Testing Patterns.
It also contains
JUnit4 rules that
can automatically start
activities and services
for your tests.
Now, I'm sure you're all eager
to see some testing in action.
So be sure to click through
to the next video, where
I show you how to run
your first Espresso test.
[MUSIC PLAYING]